wo ist ein
[Musik]
bitteschön auf die kursniveaus zum wohl
bewusst herzlichen glückwunsch nico
vielen dank liebe wusste denn jetzt
ich wohne der beginn von lisa genauer zu
erklären
eine wg das ist eine wohngemeinschaft
oder bei uns war das anders wir haben
noch bei der familie gewohnt das war
billiger
die meisten leute ziehen heute nach der
schule für die ausbildung oder studium
in andere städte oder sogar in anderen
ländern
heutzutage sieht man ja viel öfter als
früher aber man kann auch allein
es ist aber teurer meistens zu teuer ist
das wirklich so ein großer unterschied
oft schon
außerdem ist es viel schöner nicht
allein zugestimmt
mit anderen zusammen wohnen gefällt mir
auch am besten und ich wohne lieber in
einem kleinen zimmer erst mal meinen
eltern zu hause bei der das mir
natürlich auch gefallen
[Musik]
wer ist ein ppp ist mein großer bruder 8